THE STATE OF THE MARKET:
One quick Google search would
have you believe that we’re in the worst
recession since 2008. Hundreds of thousands
of people have been laid off, companies have
shed trillions of dollars worth of market cap,
and inflation has been off the charts. But at the
same time, several other metrics would suggest
that things are going just fine. I mean, just take
a look at the billionaires list. The vast majority
of billionaires are up substantially this year and
the most notable ones are up the most. Elon Musk,
up a $110 billion. Jeff Bezos, up $47 billion. And
Mark Zuckerberg, up $58 billion. The same thing
can be said about most notable stocks as well.
Netflix has recovered 175%. Meta has recovered
over 200%. And as for Apple and Nvidia, well
these guys are straight up setting all time highs.
Apple has surpassed a $3 trillion market cap and
Nvidia has joined the trillion dollar club. Also,
it’s not just these big tech companies that are
doing well either. McDonalds, all time high. Louis
Vuitton, all time high. Eli Lilly, all time high.
And even Bitcoin, one of the riskest assets on
the planet has recovered a 100%. As such, I don’t
think you’d be surprised to hear that the S&P 500
is doing pretty well too. The index has recovered
27% and it’s only 7.5% away from all time highs.
Inflation has also cooled down substantially
to just 4%. By the time you’re watching this,
inflation may even be in the 3% range. Margin
levels have also dropped significantly from nearly
a trillion dollars down to pre pandemic levels of
$644 billion. So, where exactly is all this fear
coming from. Why are companies seemingly bracing
for some sort of great depression type event and
why are finance YouTubers constantly saying that
the collapse is just around the corner. Oh wait,
that’s just for views but what about the first
point. What do companies know that we don’t? Is
all of these stock rallies just a fake out
before we plunge far deeper into a big bad
recession. Or has this market correction
simply been vastly overhyped since the
very beginning. Join me as we uncover the truth
behind the 2023 recession: aka the great reset.
RECESSION DEBUNKED:
First of all, we are not in a
recession. Economically speaking, a recession
is defined as 2 quarters of GDP decline. This
is the graph of America’s GDP over the past 5
years. Clearly, there has been no such declines
since the beginning of the pandemic. But, wait a
minute, weren’t we in a mild recession in 2022. I
swear there were articles claiming that we were
officially in a recession. Well, there actually
wasn’t any articles that were claiming that. If
we set our search time frame to the second half
of last year and look up “US enters a recession”,
we’ll see that every single reputable news outlet
framed the the topic as a question as opposed to
a statement of fact. The ones that were claiming
it as fact were actually just YouTubers. Now,
there was some truth to what they were saying.
What these guys were looking at was real GDP or
inflation adjusted GDP where there was indeed a
substantial decline from $20 trillion to $19.9
trillion or a whopping 0.5%. As you can see, the
decline was virtually nothing. For perspective,
the covid recession was nearly 10% but that’s
just the most blatant issue with calling this a
recession. For starters, even by the traditional
definition, a recession refers to nominal GDP
decline not inflation adjusted GDP decline. This
is why the 2020 recession is highlighted with
a gray bar while the supposed 2022 recession
is not. But more importantly, this rule is just a
general idea. If there’s two consecutive quarters
of GDP decline, then hey, maybe the economy is not
doing so great. But, the reality is that there’s
so many more factors that are needed to gauge
real economic health than just GDP. For example,
you may also wanna consider the unemployment
rate, non farm payroll, industrial production,
and retail sales just to name a few. Here’s
a graph of unemployment for example. Nearly
at all time lows. So, objectively speaking, we
were never in a recession in 2022 but what about
looking forward? What about the 2023 and 2024
recession and the great reset? Well, everyday,
that’s looking less and less likely as well. For
a recession to happen, we would first need to
build up some negative momentum. You know, things
like increasing unemployment, more layoffs, lower
salaries, and so on. But not only is this not
happening, but the exact opposite is happening.
We’re gaining positive momentum. Layoffs have
substantially slowed down with the peak being back
in January. In fact, the layoffs this June were
actually lower than layoffs last June. Payroll
growth has also gained some positive momentum with
April and May being positive months. Also, as we
touched on at the beginning, inflation has cooled
off quite well and blue chip stocks are doing
better than anyone expected. With that being said,
the general fear was simply a case of the general
public eating up media and YouTube fear mongering
but what about big tech stocks. Initially,
these got destroyed due to big money selling off.
These guys clearly have more insight than the
general public right. Why were they so scared of a
potential recession and especially interest rates?
INTEREST RATE HIKES DEBUNKED:
By far the number one thing that
was referenced as the big tech company killer was
rising interest rates. Basically, the entirety
of big tech happened within the past 15 years
during which interest rates were literally 0. So,
there was a lot of anxiety regarding how high
interest rates would affect these massive growth
companies. But there’s just one fatal flaw with
this concern. Most of the biggest tech companies
in the world are no longer growth companies to
begin with. Yes, they still put up insane growth
numbers year after year but that’s not at the cost
of profit. Traditional growth companies sacrifice
profitability to achieve growth. Likely the best
examples are Uber and all the food delivery apps.
But, this is not the case with Google or Apple
or Facebook or Microsoft. I’m sure you already
know how profitable these companies are but lets
go through their annual net profit for fun. Apple,
$112 billion. Microsoft, $85 billion. And Google,
$71 billion. Do you really think these companies
are suddenly at risk due to interest rates rising
from 2% to 5%? Of course not and this has become
abundantly clear within the past 12 months.
Take Apple for example. They have a total of
$100 billion in debt. For one, most of this debt
was locked in year ago, so it’s not like Apple
is having to pay a whole lot more all of a sudden.
But even if we assume that all of Apple’s debt was
affected by the interest rate hikes, it’s not
that big of a deal. Even if Apple’s rates got
hiked from 2% up to 7%, we’re only talking about
an extra $5 billion. It’s crazy to refer to that
as only but at Apple’s scale, it truly is just
only. With $112 billion worth of annual profit,
an extra $5 billion would only reduce their
profitability by 4.5% and that’s if the interest
hit their bottom line directly. You can bet that
they’re gonna write the interest off on taxes,
so the real cost to profitability would be like
3%. In other words, most of the big tech companies
are completely unaffected by the rate hikes.
Now, if we’re talking about SPACs and hype plays,
that’s a wholenother story, but to be
honest, those deserved to get wrecked.
Companies with strong fundamentals really had no
issues but that’s only half the puzzle. The other
argument was that investors would no longer be
interested in these companies. When you can make
5% guaranteed by lending to the government or
7% by lending to big corporations with bonds,
why in the world would you invest in stocks?
Well, this does have some truth to it. If you’re a
conservative investor, the answer is no reason at
all. Statistically speaking, the average investor
has no chance of beating average market returns of
7 to 8%. So, if you can get nearly the same thing
with bonds, why invest in something that’s far
riskier? Well, the answer is that that’s literally
the job of most of big money. While they suck at
beating the market, their job is to indeed try to
beat the market. The best way to do that over the
past 10 years was to invest in big tech. Will this
work again? Well, no one knows especially with
AI making big leaps. But, one things for sure,
a lot of big money is rotating back into tech
despite all the fear. But if there’s no recession
and big tech companies are doing just fine,
why in the world did we see so many layoffs?
LAYOFFS DEBUNKED:
Naturally, everyone associates layoffs with
recessions. So, when even the biggest names
started laying off, everyone assumed that we were
surely in a recession or that we were heading into
one shortly but that’s not actually the case. You
see, much of the layoffs weren’t caused by some
sort of macro economic trend but rather micro
economic trends within tech. By far the biggest
factor throwing things off balance over the past
few years was Covid. When Covid showed up and
everyone hunkered down, they naturally flocked to
things that they could do at home. This meant more
time spent on Netflix, social media, smartphones,
computers, and the internet in general. As such,
the demand for these products skyrocketed. In
fact, many tech companies had to scale their
operations specifically to keep up with this
demand. The problem was that many of these
companies assumed that this was the new normal
and that demand would continue to growing at this
rate. As such, they hired a crap ton of employees.
Google’s employee count exploded from 118,000
to 190,000. Facebook’s employee count exploded
from 45,000 to 86,000. And Amazon’s employee
count exploded from 800,000 to 1.6 million. As
you might guess, these guys were in for quite
a rude awakening when people started spending
money elsewhere. On eating out, vacations, music
festivals, physical stores, transportation, and
so on. People never stopped spending money, that’s
why our GDP has continued to grow. But people did
pull back on their tech intake whether that be in
terms of time or money. This was especially true
for pandemic specific tech companies like Zoom who
have simply gotten obliterated. At the same time
that growth rates were slowing down, productivity
numbers were also slowing down. You see, all of
this crazy hiring naturally brought in a lot of
sub par people into these companies. Existing
employees also become a lot less productive
because they had 10 job offers waiting outside, so
they were by no means scared of getting fired. You
also had all these movements like quiet quitting.
Basically, all of this simply meant that these
companies were dealing with more rest and vesters
than ever. For obvious reasons, this put companies
at quite a big hiring disadvantage. Not only were
they constantly having to offer larger and larger
compensation packages but the employees that
they were hiring were less and less effective.
It was a lose lose scenario for these companies.
Fortunately for them, layoffs gave them the
perfect way to work their way out of this vicious
cycle. So, all these layoffs that we read about
on the news aren’t really indicative of the macro
economic climate. It’s really just indicative of
the tech world which did indeed have a correction
coming off the pandemic high. Zooming out though,
we’re not in a recession but a recession
is inevitable. With that being said though,
no one knows when that’s gonna be. When everyone
thinks that it’s gonna be in 6 or 12 months,
that’s how you know that it’s definitely not
going to be in 6 or 12 months. You can’t expect
a recession. If you expect a recession, you’ll do
things to prepare for the downturn which will in
turn prevent the recession from even happening.
Recessions happen when the general public is
overconfident in the market which is definitely
not the case right now. So, the best option is to
just forget trying to predict the next recession
and stick to a strong investment plan that works
over the long term whether that be buying the S&P
500 or investing in bonds but that’s just what I
think. Someone that’s actually facing a recession
is TikTokers. Check out this video to learn more.